439000 c'est notre chiffre du jour il
s'agit du nombre de plis de propagande
électorale que les facteurs devait
livrer dans les boîtes aux lettres des
particuliers en indre et loire loir et
cher et qu'ils étaient 243 milles une
charge de travail supplémentaire mais
ponctuelles pour la poste après de
graves dysfonctionnements constatés lors
des dernières élections chez leurs
concurrents le groupe a récupéré le
marché c'est mal colin
voitures chargées du double de plis
postaux habituelle pendant quatre jours
c'est le coup de bourre 40000 propagande
électorale à distribuer et cela commence
ici au tri ils sont une quarantaine à
préparer les tournées chaque électeur
est supposé recevoir un de ses courriers
au temps d'arrêt en plus pour les
facteurs zac les élections c'est
toujours as toujours un surplus de
travail mais s'est offert mesure des
années au bout de
16 17 ans comme ancêtre est trop d'aix
sur les présidentielles et municipales
législatives et aux régionales le centre
de fondettes gère un ensemble de
communes du nord du département entre
bourgueil saint paterne racan et
neuillé-pont-pierre ce matin vincent
prépare une de ses tournées les
propagandes sont triés et répartis parmi
le courrier habituel pour qu'on aille
aux élections on à la presse donc la
paix une petite est urgente ensuite on
alcohol ordinaire notre verte lettres
rouges la publicité aussi lors des
élections départementales et régionales
de l'année dernière la distribution des
plis est sous-traitée à l'entreprise
adrexo à l'époque la commission des lois
du sénat estime qu'entre 25 et 40% des
électeurs ne reçoivent aucune propagande
avant le second tour du scrutin l'état
décide alors de résilier le marché pour
le confier à nouveau au groupe la poste
évidemment en ce moment on a mis 1 on a
mis des renforts pour pour être certain
de pouvoir passer cette semaine
sereinement c'est donc on lis la charge
sur les quatre jours qu'on a pour
distribuer et la poste se prépare déjà à
l'entre-deux tours les équipes auront
alors seulement trois jours pour
distribuer les professions de foi des
deux candidats